I want to start today with a very well done
Yahoo news investigation, which reveals that
the entire Seth rich conspiracy theory from
a couple of really, I guess three years ago
at this point, was a planted and fomented
by Russian intelligence. And this is a pretty
stunning and particularly disturbing revelation
because of how successful this conspiracy
theory was. I mean, remember this conspiracy
theory penetrated not only the right, but
even some enclaves of left wing media, um,
uh, the, the wackier elements admittedly,
but it did get into the left as well. And
the idea of this conspiracy theory, and again,
as I often say with these things, if this
is news to you, if you didn't even hear about
the fact that this was actually getting some
traction, I envy you. I wish I had never heard
about the fact that this was going on, but
the theory was that Seth rich, a DNC staffer,
was not actually killed in a robbery gone
wrong, but rather by associates of Hillary
Clinton because he simply knew too much possibly
about Hillary's emails or hacking of the DNC
emails, which wasn't really actually what
it was claimed to be, or because of Hillary's
corruption that he knew about and that he
was killed in July of 2016 um, in order to
ensure his silence and that what he knew would
never go public, including through wikileaks
with whom he was allegedly according to some
flavors of the conspiracy in touch.
Um, right after the, uh, incident in which
rich was killed in July of 2016, the SVR,
which is Russia's foreign intelligence service,
started fomenting the idea that this was not
as reported, not a robbery gone wrong, but
instead it was because he was, Seth rich was
just so close to telling the FBI or wikileaks
or whoever about all of the corrupt dealings
of Hillary Clinton. So he was killed. Um,
the truth of course is that rich was killed
when walking home from a bar in Washington,
d c he was on the phone with his girlfriend
at the time and he was shot twice in the back
of the head. And an element of the story that
is sometimes included is that there were these
connections with Julian Assange is wikileaks.
And then after the SVR initially participated
in creating this conspiracy, the Internet
research agency, which is this Russian troll
factory, which we've talked about before,
which engages in social media, disinformation
campaigns, started aggressively circulating
the conspiracy and getting it more auction.
And of course we know that it was eventually
spread by allies of Donald Trump, including
Roger Stone. Steve Bannon said it was a quote,
contract kill, obviously end quote Trump attorney
Jay Sekulow said it, quote, sure doesn't look
like a robbery. Sean Hannity ended up running
with it. We saw Alex Jones talk about it.
I believe I'm going from memory now. And then
even some elements of the left were spreading
this conspiracy theory, shockingly, I'm not
even going to name them. You can research
them if that's interesting to you. Uh, now
I don't even know that I need to point out
some of the problems with the conspiracy theory.
There are many, but I'll include, uh, just
a few, uh, one being the big picture that
Seth rich was merely a data analyst. He didn't
have access to nor the technical knowhow to
hack and access what he would have needed
to access.
His parents have corroborated that he didn't
have the knowledge. There's no evidence that's
been found that Seth rich had any information
that he was in contact with anybody at wikileaks
to whom he would have sent that information.
But it doesn't matter because the propagators
of this will continue to believe it and try
to propagate it. And they are already even
saying that the Yahoo News report pointing
to Russian intelligence has fomenting this
conspiracy is part of the planted fake backstory
meant to take attention away from the fact
that this was a contract kill or a, a murder
meant to silence Seth rich. Now, in fact,
uh, the first Seth rich, his family, this
has been terrible. Okay. Uh, Seth Rich's parents
have repeatedly asked that people just stop,
that the conspiracies are like quote, losing
him all over again. They've said. So the real
story for me here is that there's a huge overlap
between those who fell for the Seth rich conspiracy
theory and those who believe that Russia did
nothing to attack our election systems or
to help Donald Trump.
Lots of Seth rich conspiracists also see,
uh, the Russia story as a completely fabricated
one. Seth rich conspiracists are often also
Russia deniers. And it turns out that it's
the same Russian forces that claim, uh, that
they like to say did nothing at all with regard
to the election that were actually the ones
pushing this Seth rich conspiracy theory in
front of more and more people. Now, if you're
wondering why, why is it in Russia's interest
to push such a conspiracy theory? Uh, it's
the same reason that it's in their interest
to do everything that they've done. It's consistent
with Russia's desire to foment chaos and these
stabilize basic democratic systems and spreading
the notion that one of the presidential candidates
might've had someone killed before they could
blow the whistle on them if that is believed.
It contributes to this chaotic perception
or this perception that American democracy
is in absolute and total chaos.
And of course in a sense it is 60 million
people voted for Donald Trump, and that is
extraordinarily chaotic, but not in the way,
uh, that these conspiracies seek to, uh, make
people believe it is truly sick. To use a
family's tragedy to try to advance a political
agenda with a completely bogus conspiracy
theory. It's CIC for Russian intelligence
to do it. It's sick for American media to
do it. Fox News, the elements of the Left,
Alex Jones, whoever else. And most importantly,
it's really important that we just kind of
be adults about this stuff when it comes to,
Oh, you're either a Russia conspiracist or
a Russia denier and everything is completely
black and white. Russia, like many countries,
has intelligence services. They have geopolitical
priorities that they determine what they believe
to be the best ways to try to encourage the
United States does a ton of this stuff in
other countries.
This is not unique to Russia. I have not really
met anybody that I consider serious that has
this sort of horse supply minders, black,
white view of Russia is uniquely bad, evil,
whatever, or Russia is simply, uh, there's
nothing to see here whatsoever. Mostly the
people that are actually thoughtfully thinking
about this stuff. Uh, that might be a, an
oxymoron, thoughtfully thinking that it actually
thinking about this stuff. Critically see
Russia as one of many countries that has intelligence
operations and intelligence operatives all
over the world and they happen to have been
more successful than many other countries
over the last three to five years. That's
basically it. And jumping into these very
black wide, the, the black white thinking
that pervades a lot of people's minds every
time Russia is mentioned is destructive
and also counterproductive.